[Music]
anything could be you again he surprises
you
I'm tired of hiding let's take the fight
back home
I want to bring up world the ground
this thing in you it is desperate to
destroy here as we are everyone you love
all right
season finale of Marvel's agents of
shield next Tuesday ABC holy crap he's
back agents of shield finale is next
week if you guys didn't know there's
only 22 episodes in the season so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's even
guardians of the galaxy giveaway going
on now if you bailed on the series a
while ago and you have no idea what's
going on I'll explain how ghost riders
back where he went in what's going on
with the plotline the back half of the
season the important stuff first though
Ghost Rider where did he come from
so that scene was from the end of last
week's episode there was a big life
model decoy uprising they destroyed the
base that the shield agents had been
using the Peggy Carter base that was
from a way way back so that means that
if they do get renewed for season 5
they'll either have to rebuild that or
they'll have a new base of operations so
we'll get like a new big shield set and
I will address that I think they have a
really good shot at a season 5 renewal
people behind the scenes the
entertainment reporters have been saying
that it's going to happen but we'll
believe it when we see it I think a lot
of that has to do with what's going on
with the new Inhumans TV show so I'll
address that too at the end of the video
but so you're looking at the wreckage of
the shield base here so what's left over
is the big dimensional portal that ADA
built earlier this season that they used
to say Coulson and fit so it just sat
there in the base nobody thinking twice
about it during the mid-season finale
Ghost Rider's uncle was trying to become
a God using the dark hold so they built
another dimensional portal ghostwriter
sucked him into another dimension they
never say which dimension it is but the
idea is is that someday that they could
do Mephisto on the TV show so it'd be a
version of Marvel's hell or the Dark
Dimension itself not that I think
there's ever a chance of that doing
Dormammu on the TV show but maybe we'll
mention his name eventually it's just
that the Mephisto character is specific
to ghost riders origin stories so when
you're talking about Ghost Rider big
dimensional beings you're talking about
Mephisto not Dormammu but there was a
Coulson scene in last night's episode
that was perfect so I'll play that he
does this great Ghost Rider explainer so
how do things end with Robbie ray
last I remember I'm chasing down his
uncle oh you know guy tried to become a
god so we opened up a portal beneath his
quantum power cube then ghostwriter
dragged him to another dimension with
his Hellfire chain so things ended well
then they've almost gotten everybody out
of the Hydra matrix except for Mac who's
stuck in there
yo-yo went in to get him but ADA escaped
gave herself a real body using the power
of the dark hold but also at the same
time granted herself a whole bunch of
inhuman powers so a really good example
in the DC Comics universe is Amazo the
robot that can mimic the powers of
anybody from the Justice League she
programmed herself with all these
abilities so she's almost unkillable
Fitz keeps screaming she can't be
stopped she can't be stopped and then he
has that tag at the end where Ghost
Rider steps through up there you go
there's our answer
Ghost Rider can drag her back to the
Dark Dimension or wherever Mephisto
lives in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but that's pretty much where we're at
that's the big conflict of the finale is
that ADA has now like transcended to
comic book supervillain she's not just a
villain anymore now it's like full-blown
I want them to suffer so we have our
team up in the trailer Coulson is like
that thing inside you want to get rid of
her as much as we do so they're not
really clear on the motivations of the
spirit of vengeance that's inside Ghost
Rider the spirit of vengeance that the
Fisto binds to the Johnny Blaze version
of The Ghost Rider in the comics his
name's Aerith oz he's a demon that's
almost as powerful as Mephisto but I'm
not expecting them to reveal who the
spirit of vengeance is on TV Ghost Rider
but it is implied earlier this season
that when we saw the origin story for
this version of Ghost Rider it's the
Johnny Blaze version that's passing the
spirit of vengeance into him died
[Music]
and there's nothing it's just darkness
and I heard a voice was asking me if I
wanted a second chance did I want to
punish those who hurt my brother did I
want to avenge my own death
I answered yes
more than anything yes I was alive again
and you're right
someone there when I came to
that it wasn't a good smash
was the devil
whatever was inside
so ghostrider wants to help but they're
not totally clear on what his
motivations are and what the spirit of
vengeance stands to gain is they do get
rid of the super version of ADA but it's
implied that he'll also wrap up the dark
Holt plotline it's not likely going to
leave that with Coulson at the end of
the season it's way too powerful and
even Coulson didn't want to open it and
this is the big question
moving on to season 5 stuff so what's
going to happen is is they'll probably
wait till a little while after the
finale airs see how it does and then
confirm what's going on with the final
fate of agents of shield
I think it's been strong enough the back
half of the season like they've shown
that they can do really cool characters
good storylines so at the very least I
think they'll get a 13 episode order
they might get a full season five just
to wrap up everything because Marvel TV
has so many other things they're trying
to roll out that shield is kind of
getting pushed to the side so even
though it's getting really good they
have a lot of new stuff that's coming in
the Inhumans producers have been very
open about crossover potential between
agents of shield characters and their
characters they're going to be largely
self-contained for the first season and
it's only eight episodes so it's
intended to be more of like a big-budget
miniseries they're going to be airing
the first two episodes at IMAX
it's going to be a Tuesday night show
but because agents of shield is Tuesday
nights that raises a lot of questions
about what's happening with the schedule
so once they announce what the plans for
that are I'll do a video about it but
they just confirmed there's going to be
a new Deadpool animated series that's
kind of the direction that Marvel TV is
headed they're doing like the really big
Netflix series they're doing the
hardcore characters that you really want
to see on TV so I think that Shields
days are numbered unless they can do big
Ghost Rider level characters like this
on a more regular basis in ads for Ghost
Rider they don't have any plans to do a
Ghost Rider TV show right now or to do a
movie but I do think that he would fit
really well with a post defenders
Netflix Marvel Universe the defenders
are slowly pushing into more mystical
areas with the capital cities of heavens
the Iron Fist lore so doing a character
like Ghost Rider would fit a lot better
in future seasons of that but it just
depends on what they want to do with the
character I think they'll try to find a
place for him because he's really cool
and everybody's loved him this season so
far let me know in the comments what do
you want them to do with agents of
shield if they do get picked up for
season 5 and what
you want them to do with the Ghost Rider
character but either way there's going
to be crazy new Marvel TV I think a lot
of the new stuff is going to be really
cool so we'll just see what it looks
like when we get there but these are the
videos that I'm going to be working on
the next day and a half I'll try to get
through them as fast as possible there's
a whole bunch of footage to get through
all of it looks really good but next is
going to be my arrow video so that'll
post later tonight while you wait to
that click here for new flash and click
here for all my guardians of the galaxy
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys tonight